yeah dude [ __ ] yeah of course you know
scott randolph yes of course we're
without paul briskey
first paul
tested pauses for kovan oh [ __ ] man what
a [ __ ]
he's like i feel fine
so i'm walking out of here
yeah coughing tomorrow no no no no like
we're both negative yeah i'm not
tested positive for the virus once
man i swear
i think i had it before it got in that
like in december i got the all this
except i never lost myself i have no
idea but i got really sick as i've been
in december before the shoot came out my
uh
my my one positive test was for
antibodies
yeah i never did that i should have done
that just to find out but i don't think
even it was available how many times you
guys test each other for jackass
and then yeah i was doing
three times a week during post and all
that so
and um
that's gonna add to the budget of
jackass four
how much was it
i don't know the final number but it's
over over a mill i think like just which
means a lot to us
no just the whole thing like
god i know a guy who
did like security he runs a security
company with the studios and stuff and
he pivoted during this and they just
print money
yeah and they're just [ __ ] they mean
a security security company that did you
know like keeps a set secure and then
this [ __ ]
pandemic hit and the studios need to now
do so much testing and he was all set up
he just had to do some classes and
switch pivot over to covet safety i'm
sorry not i mean covet is a money maker
man
an ex-girlfriend of mine got her medical
something and she's able to sell ppe's
and she was just flipping containers out
at sea for like 40 grand a pop yeah it's
like okay cool yeah have a buyer great
we'll get you so the first question that
i've got to ask is like how
the [ __ ] is this movie coming
i don't know it's it's nerve-wracking to
see i mean it's crazy because you've got
that like the polar extremes of like
craziest covet ever and biggest box
office revenue ever happening
simultaneously and that doesn't help the
case to push it because right and you're
also hearing that this one's not as bad
like it's just you're now they've
shortened most big people have shortened
the window if you test positive it's
five days now cdc has done it like nfl's
doing it and then if you test negative
twice you're back in like oh you gotta
test negative twice huh i think for the
nfl i think that's what it is um i don't
know but the cdc doesn't tell you that
just there's a quarantine is shrunk but
that that weekend that spider-man did
domestic opening of 253 million
it was a different week than what we're
getting into i know i know yeah it's
nerve-wracking i don't know you know we
gotta we're each day's [ __ ] yeah and
um you know hey man like i i'm gonna do
everything in in my power to
promote this movie and it's not gonna
hurt my feelings if i promote it you
know in the spring no we all
have vested reasons do we want this
thing to do well exactly
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town
with my bucket list tour what is it well
it's an x-rated show full of all the
stuff that i would have never have been
allowed to do for jackass and a lot of
it is flagrantly illegal so it's adults
only and if you live in any of these
states then you better go to stevo.com
and check out my tour schedule hurry up
and get your tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]